what okay welcome back everyone we're
gonna start uh our next talk which is
the last talk before lunch and this is a
talk by Eric wein Garten fast algorithms
for a new relaxation of optimal
transport okay well well thanks Jani um
I want to thank the organizers and
everyone's
flexibility um yeah so I'm going to talk
about uh fast algorithms for for a new
relaxation OT stands for optimal
transport we'll get into the problems
and this is Joint work with Moses charar
uh batty Chen and Chris Ray and if you
guys don't know batty and Chris uh so
they're more ml systems people and well
Chris is a professor at Stanford and
batty she was also postto with me uh at
Stanford with Chris um and kind of the
way that this project originated is that
well Batty's like her research is all
about building um reliable systems in ml
and she uses all the sketching and
locality sensitive hashing techniques
that we talk about in theory um so
really this uh this project started as a
way to see okay what kind of interesting
questions we could ask uh that Moses and
I are interested in and that could
potentially lead to something that um
they think is kind of
useful okay
um I think the most important part of
this talk is really going to be an open
problem that I'm going to state so I'll
state it first and then everything I'm
going to say after that is going to be
just maybe Epsilon amount of progress
toward that open
problem but the premise is that we're
going to talk about algorithmic
problems um of of this geometric type of
questions and the premise is going to be
that the fact that these problems are
have some degree of
non-locality is GNA it's going to be
what makes these problems
algorithmically difficult okay so for
now in the rest of the talk my input is
always going to be two sets of
vectors um X1 through xn that's my one
set and y1 through YN these are vectors
in Rd and you should think about what's
called like the so-called
high-dimensional regime and and all this
means is that the dimensionality D is
significantly larger than log n but less
than n to the little o one okay and
we'll care about the dependence on N um
and this dependence is saying well you
don't want to be exponential in the
dimension uh but if you pay arbitrary
pols in D maybe that's
okay okay now let me Define three
problems and these are very related when
I say it but algorithmic Tech Al they're
going to turn out to be somewhat
different and that's going to be the
main open problem so the first on the
left and these problems are going to be
ordered from I guess my notion of least
local to uh sorry to from most local to
least local so the first problem is the
closest pair problem the idea is well
you just the task with finding what is
the pair of points I in corresponding to
indexing X and indexing Y which
minimizes the ukian distance between
them the second problem is maybe a
slightly more complicated version of
that is called the chamfer distance
problem and if you're here for a p indix
talk I think tomorrow he'll talk about
an algorithm to solve this problem this
is essentially a sum of nearest neighbor
problem okay so you're given X and Y
what is the objective well you want to
minimize or in some sense you want to
compute the sum for each each point x i
the distance to its nearest neighbor YJ
okay and lastly and this will be kind of
the main player in this talk is the
earth mover distance and what I think
about is maybe the the more complex
version of this problem is that now you
also want to have for each point in x a
corresponding distance to Something in y
but there's going to be a matching
constraint so I'm minimizing overall
permutations pi and the sum of distances
is from x i to the corresponding matched
pair in y
[Applause]
yeah what's
[Music]
minimization I think this is a typo so
the first thing is yeah um it'll be
clear why I had this typo in a
second okay so these are the three
problems and uh in order to highlight
kind of what the I mean they they are
different but for us I'm going to write
these problems as linear
programs where essentially I'm going to
be optimizing over an N byn Matrix where
each of these gamma gamma i j is going
to correspond to how much we care about
the pair XI with YJ okay so all these
problem
they have the variables being gamma i j
for each I and J and N so there's n s
many variables and we want to minimize
over essentially the sum of IJ gamma
times the distance okay so now the only
difference in all these three problems
is what constraints we impose on this
Matrix gamma so for the closest pair
problem you're essentially trying to say
okay all these gamas should be positive
and the total sum should be one
so naturally this will pick the minimum
distance for chamfer you go and if you
think about the rows being index by X
and the columns by y then we're going
through each row and we're saying that
want to minimize this this linear
objective function such that the sum of
every row is equal to one this again is
going to pick for each point in XI its
nearest neighbor in y That's the minimum
value of the distance
and finally EMD the more complicated
version is going to add not only the row
constraints summing up to one but also
this Matrix has to be W stochastic so
the column sums also have to be
one okay so this is really what I'm
going to mean by EMD has a very funny
thing that if you have a particular
solution let's say
gamma and you change a particular entry
you want to increase or decrease well if
you want to say match I to J well
whatever J was match to now you need to
change it and that's G to make another
change and so I mean if you're aware
with this uh the Hungarian algorithm
these exactly are the alternating cycles
that you need to be
making and the fact that kind of a small
local change can have dramatic
consequences on what you need to do in
order to maintain these two constraints
this makes it algor mically very
difficult to reason
about and the main question here is uh
what can we approximate accurately in
near linear time so here I need to be
very specific about what I mean by near
linear time because the input to the
problem is just the end point in Rd so
the input size is n * D but this linear
program it has N squared many variables
so even writing down this formulation of
the problem it would be too expensive
okay so by near linear time I really
mean like n poly log n um and by
approximating accurately I mean that I
want my approximations to be up to
multiplicative one plus or minus
Epsilon U and the dependence on Epsilon
is going to be an arbitrary polinomial
okay so I'll get more El roughly
speaking this is the regime that we're
working
with
cool so what's the open problem
well as you go from this problem over to
these problems I understand these
problems less and less and even
though this problem is the least
local um there's still it still could
potentially be very easy so the first
thing is that actually optimizing this
is hard in the sense that I mean Josh
spoke about it yesterday that if you
could solve this problem in time which
is n poly log n over poly Epsilon this
would break set okay so we believe that
there's no such
algorithms but now when you move on to
the chamfer distance it is both hard and
easy hard in the sense that if you
actually wanted to Output a solution
gamma and by solution because the
solution is the nearest neighbors is a
sparse the optimum there exists a sparse
solution so you could ask I want to
output for each I the corresponding J
that's the nearest neighbor such that
the optimum will give something which is
up to 1 plus or minus Epsilon the
correct thing this is hard this would
break not Seth but another complexity
theoretic assumption it's called The
Hitting set
assumption uh but at the same time it's
easy if all you cared about was an
algorithm which could approximate the
cost so if you didn't care about
outputting a sparse representation of
gamma which in theory you could this is
hard if you just wanted to approximate
this this cost it turns out there's a
one plus or minus Epsilon approximation
algorithm that runs in N poly log end
time this is Joint work with aesh faki P
indic who's gonna speak about it
tomorrow Rajesh gyam sandip who's in the
audience
um so this middle problem is hard to
Output a solution easy to approximate
the cost of the
solution and an EMD we don't know so we
know that it's hard in the same way that
chamfer distance is hard if I wanted to
Output a solution um it would break this
hitting set hypothesis the same
complexity theoretic assumption um
however the open problem is I still
don't know whether there exists a near
linear time algorithm that can output a
1 plus or minus Epsilon approximation to
the
cost so I would love to solve that
problem and if anybody's interested you
also should let me know because I'm
still very interested in it um
and in this talk what I'll tell you
about
is how even though we're stuck on this
problem there is a slight modification
that I could make to the problem which
admits other kinds of algorithmic
techniques yeah please at any time feel
free to stop me yeah multipli
approximations yeah so it's 1 plus minus
Epsilon approximation to EMD with time
which is n poly log n polyd divided by
poly Epsilon so I'm okay with the
polinomial dependence and Epsilon don't
need to worry that the scale of the
first problem is like a little different
than the scale of the other problems yes
that's right so this is going to sum end
distances but this will only sum one
distance
yeah yeah what if you want a constant
just a constant approximation is still
hard so yeah so that's a good question
so for a constant Factor
approximation uh we don't know any
hardness results but we're
also there's something you can say in
the regime where you're allowed slightly
above linear time so if I say like ENT
to the 1 plus Epsilon then we know how
to design algorithms which are roughly
approximation o of one over maybe square
root Epsilon now I mean this I'll get
into it in a second this will be like
another kind of regime and like large
approximation regime where we can say
something
interesting all right so here's the
outline of the remainder of the talk so
first I'm going to tell you about this
so-called spanner approach and this is
the kind of in line with what Cliff was
asking this is the one technique that we
have in order to solve these problems up
to say some large constant Factor
approximation or even larger
approximations um which at a high level
are reductions to graph problems so we
take our geometric problem this is some
linear program but you could express it
as a graph the spanner approach is a way
to reduce to a graph problem such that
you can solve the corresponding graph
problem and then I'll tell you about
kind of another line of work uh from the
more applied ml Community where they
also change the optimal transport
problem uh where not studying this earth
mover distance problem but they're
introducing a different kind of
objective uh it's called the synchron
distance and that's going to be very
related to the kind of goals that we set
for
ourselves and then I'll tell you the
main result and how we were able to do
something different and what that
different
is okay so here's a spanner approach and
I'm encapsulating the entire spanner
approach by this one theorem of harped
indic and cedris and 13 but you should
really think about it as a way to reduce
my geometric problem to a sparse graph
problem so graph that doesn't have n squ
many edges such that the corresponding
Solution on the graph will correspond to
the geometric problem up to some
approximation and here the theorem says
that if you want to build a graph which
is which has that its distances is a c
approximate um it it approx Ates a
distance in the graph up to factor of C
of the original distance then you can
build a graph in time which is n^ the 1
+ O of 1 over c^2 so as you allow a
larger approximation C this overhead on
linear time is going to go to zero but
for any fixed constant it's still some
constant and the fact that you can do
this in this amount of time means that
the number of edges in the graph that
you produce has at least at most those
number of edges
and now I don't have like a precise
theorem for this statement but it turns
out to be the case that for a lot of
these geometric questions not only the
closest pair or chamfer or um this EMD
there's a very close relationship
between
the the time complexity of building
these graphs of doing these reductions
to graph problems and the time that it
takes to solve the approximate nearest
neighbors problem so I mean this is not
a formal statement but it turns out that
the way that you solve for these build
these graph spanners what you end up
doing is you end up essentially building
poly log many approximate nearest
neighbor data structures and then you
query that data structure end times in
order to like locally connect each point
to a few of its neighbors so here this
what the expression is that usually the
time complexity is the N times the query
time for approximate nearest neighbors
plus the time that it takes to build
this data structure
okay and the truth is that we don't know
how to get very accurate approximations
for approximate nearest Neighbors when
the the underlying Dimension is high so
we don't have say poly
log uh time algorithms or n poly log n
space data structures that get accurate
1 plus Epsilon approximations so in this
regime of 1 plus Epsilon
approximations um we have to pay this
polinomial overhead in the spanner
constructions and I think this is really
well for us it was kind of a conceptual
Challenge and something that when we
started talking to uh batty and Chris it
was really something that this was maybe
the the point of contention is that um
the conceptual challenge is that these
accurate approximations essentially end
up taking quadratic time if you do want
to build a span
where this factor of C is something like
1 plus Epsilon you're going to start
seeing running times which are like n
the 2 minus some function of Epsilon
this is something that Josh spoke about
yesterday as
well and yeah like I said it's not only
for the optimal transport if you want to
Output solutions for say the ukian
minimum spanning tree the closest pair
and all these problems they'll
essentially run in time n the 2 minus
Epsilon order Epsilon some function of
Epsilon except there's one problem and
this problem has already come up in this
Workshop a few times of the kernel
density estimation problem where there
are some instances where we can get one
plus or minus Epsilon approximations in
running times which are near
linear okay so these were really our
motivating uh kind of questions and oh
let me tell you about kind of Sy horn
distances what do people do so okay so
in theory we often Time study the earth
mover distance um and we have if we want
fast algorithms we really end up with
crude approximations by setting this
factor C um to be large and using the
spanner approach on the other hand if
you look at the machine learning
literature then they change the problem
slightly and I won't get into the
precise definition but it's something
that also feels like Optimal
transport uh they get very accurate
additive approximations so if you think
of all your points as lying with and say
a ball of radius R they can approximate
the value of this optimal transport
synor problem up to plus or minus
Epsilon R so it's an accurate
approximation if you're allowed to be
additive uh but the algorithms are quite
slow essentially they have to
materialize this entire N squared uh
many distances they essentially they
work on this Matrix gamma
directly so our motivating questions
were okay from the theory side can we
break break away from uh this spanner
approach can we build some techniques um
and maybe more generally we are flexible
in the definition of the problem say
okay so sorn they have already changed
the problem so uh which kind of
Transport can we develop algorithms
form okay so now I'll tell you kind of
what our relaxation is so the the main
idea was to focus on a slight
perturbation of EMD and okay this is
another typo should think about these
encode my constraints that the row sums
should be equal to mu+ the column sums
should be equal to Mu
minus and I'm rewriting the earth mover
distance Problem by saying well let me
first consider this Vector which I'll
call the cost Vector for gamma which is
an N Square dimensional vector and for
entry i j I'm just going to give you the
cost that this linear program pays for
this particular setting of gamma so it's
just be gamma i j how how much mass you
send from I to J times x i minus okay
this should be YJ and then earth mover
distance just a minimum over gamma
satisfying this constraints of the L1
Norm of this cost
Vector so yeah so that's the that's just
the reformulation of the problem and our
twist is to say okay let's we won't
solve the earth mover distance problem
but what we are going to solve is
instead of looking at the L1 Norm
minimize the L1 Norm over gamma we're
going to minimize the L row Norm of this
cost Vector okay so my new problem is to
say Okay I want to minimize over these
matrices gamma which are bigger than
zero such that I minimize the l r Norm
of this cost
okay so if I write it down this just
looks like a sum over each entry I gamma
i j time the distance raised to the
power row all raised to the one over row
yeah yeah so row is gonna be something
bigger than one and the kind of the the
reason why this was our compromise is to
say that as row approaches
one whatever you output is going to
approach their mover distance but it's
going to turn out that for every setting
of row this problem is algorithmically
much easier
[Applause]
any questions on the formulation I think
this is probably one of the most
important
[Applause]
things okay cool now maybe you're
familiar with a different kind of
optimal transport that's called the
werstein P
distances
um they're very similar they want to
they're very similar to EMD
um but they want you to minimize the sum
of powers of distances now this looks
related but it's different because in
watstein P you don't raise gamma i j to
power P you're just saying my costs are
now distances to some power for us it's
very important that we raise the
variable gamma i j to power row and this
makes the problem just just a different
problem that's why it's going to be
algorithmically easy for the same
reasons we don't know how to solve EMD
in near linear time we also don't know
how to solve these waserstein P
distances time
[Applause]
yeah if you look at this objective
function for the first time it's hard to
know maybe it's worthwhile saying how
should one think of the optimum
solutions to this problem relative to
EMD is there a way to think about how
the solutions def
so like how intuitively we think about
yeah intuitively yeah so okay good so
what is the goal the goal is to minimize
this thing and now when you're trying to
let's think of the cost Vector when
you're trying
to take the L1 Norm of a cost Vector
you're just taking the sums of the entri
but now if before that I raise each
entry to the power row I essentially
want to make sure that
your entries aren't big I can spread
them out as much as possible because if
I take let's say a vector which sums up
to One D L1 Norm but now I compute the
L2 Norm if the entries were kind of
spread out then this will be
significantly smaller so this this
optimization problem is trying to find
ways to kind of send mass from the
points x i to
XJ which minimize this objective in in a
way that it also encourages you to send
your mass out to other
[Applause]
points now you can come up with a like
you can relate
multiplicatively the objective the true
value of this quantity and the true
value of this quantity and this is
because the L row Norm is related to the
L1 norm and that would give you an
approximation of row as going to one
essentially becomes n^ 2 to the power of
1 over
row no one
over row minus one some some quantity as
row goes to one this thing approaches
this and you can come up with the multi
what multiplicative approximation would
you be getting um but these
multiplicative approximations are not
super interesting because they're
polinomial approximations so they're
strictly it would be strictly dominated
by the spanner approach you really cared
about this problem the best thing we
know is still the spanner approach but
for this this different problem that's
going to be algorithmically
easier okay so let me tell you just the
main
theorem um which is just an algorithm
for this um this new objective function
this new
relaxation and the new theorem says that
for any row where I set row bigger than
one and any Epsilon so I'm going to get
these accurate Epsilon approximations
there's an algorithm which receives us
input these two sets of points and in
time which okay this this expression is
a little bit complicated to par but
there's n so that's our linear time and
the overhead is going to be a small
polinomial of of row for which as row
goes to one this gets arbitrarily close
to to zero um something that's going to
depend exponentially in one over one
over row minus one so as row goes to one
this term is going to be the thing that
blows
up divided by poly Epsilon so these are
going to be the Epsilon accurate
parameter and it's going to Output an
additive Epsilon R approximation so all
my vectors live in a ball of radius
R okay so I'm changing the problem in a
few ways first and most importantly I
changed the objective now as row goes to
one this thing approaches EMD but my
running time is going to blow up because
this term this exponential in one over
row this quantity becomes very small and
hence this exponential becomes very
large um but we can approximate up to
some plus or minus Epsilon R something
that we don't know how to do with
E
Yeah so as row is
large as row is large this is also exp
like if row is two this could be like
arbitrary polinomial in N yeah so yeah
good so it is also true that when our
algorithm and I think this is a weakness
of our algorithm right um the running
time it's important that row be bigger
than one if it's too close to one it
blows up and if it's further than one it
also blows up okay and then like one
other quick question is if you didn't
power up the gamas it didn't matter if
you change the ukian distance to like
ukian distance to the row you said the
hardness results carry over is the same
in your formulation like does it matter
that you change the distance to the ukan
like if you had just powered up the
gamas and not powered up the Norms would
it have affected anything that's a good
question I don't
know if row is really large do you know
the problem is hard because it seems
like it might be easy right because it's
sort of like a becomes like a threshold
problem
right not this gthm but the problem in
general row is large yeah it could yeah
I don't know I would have let's maybe
talk
about um but I wanted to just post one
parameterization of row where I think
kind of highlights the the newness if
you think of row as something like 1 +
1/ root log n now you are getting near
linear almost linear time algorithms
which get additive plus or minus Epsilon
R approximations to a different problem
let's
[Applause]
do uh just two Qui clarifying questions
first of all is this outputting an
approximation to the optimal cost or is
this outputting an approximate
solution yeah that's a good question
so they will only output an approximate
solution and the the reason is that for
these cases you don't know that the
optimal row is
sparse sorry the optimal gamma the
optimal like assignment now gamma is the
minimum over these matrices and they're
all kind of non- negative and it's going
to have small injuries but they could be
sparse now for the Min cost matching
question for EMD you know that the
optimal gamma is going to be Spar so you
could hope to Output a solution it turns
out to be hard um but for this problem
we can't hope to Output the solution
because the solutions may not be Spar
okay so it does output the near optimal
score then not the okay yeah great and
also can you rem me what little r is
yeah little r is going to be the radius
of so let's think about r as all these
points are within distance at most R so
the biggest value Val that this could
take would be each point has the point R
so the scale of the problem is maybe R
time n thank you so following up on that
do you have like uh quy access to this
gam this uh Matrix like if I just care
about the one three entry can this
algorithm give you that value yes yes we
do and also let me say that what I said
before is slightly wrong the if if we're
we're taking the sums of distances then
the scale of the problem is Epsilon is R
* n because we're summing n distances
which could be from 0 to R and our
approxim I'm missing a factor of n here
so it's EP additive Epsilon Epsilon with
respect to the scale of the
[Applause]
problem so this is our concession in a
way um there are these fast algorithms
for computing EMD but they get large
crude approximations um on the other
hand we have these synor type of
algorithms these are slow these take
quadratic time uh but they achieve this
additive Epsilon RN approximation so
well this is another class of optimal
transport problems which you can say
something that looks like the synchron
running
times uh but sorry synchron kind of
approximations but at the same time have
running times which look like the very
fast EMD
[Applause]
algorithm okay so now let me tell you
about why this problem is different and
why we can um solve it and why this
minor change makes a big change
algorithmically and it's related to this
problem that um there were some talks
yesterday on the Kernel density
estimation and I'll tell you about kind
of the relationship
between okay so I'm going to go through
this slide pretty quickly because
Moses's talk yesterday kind of introduce
the problem so what is a problem the
kernel density estimation well it's a
problem where you have some data set X1
through xn and there's going to be a
kernel function and you should think
about this function as some function
that decays as the points X and Y get
further away from each
other so for instance one possible
kernel function is something like one
over the distance squared Okay now
what's the goal the goal is to design a
data structure that can uh store these
points such that in the future a new
point is going to come and your goal is
to approximate the average value so as
kind of Moses said yesterday um you're
trying to say what is the aggregate
force that each of the points X1 through
xn is exerting on the point on the query
point
[Applause]
Y and there's been some work uh on this
kernel density estimation problem I'm
not going to get into it but I think
there's been some works that very carry
a very strong conceptual message that
this notion of smoothness or how exactly
this function K decays as a function of
distance is very helpful for solving
these kind of problems so in particular
I'm referring to this paper of bakur
charikar IND
milakis um who showed that if you have a
kernel where this function K decays
polom with the distance so it's
something like in this case this would
be a degree s smooth kernel then there
exist data structures for approximating
KDE um in time which are going to be
poly Log In N with a to 1 plus minus
Epsilon approximations which a parameter
which grows exponentially but only in
the smoothness parameter
s so the yeah so that's the main message
and I guess I think about uh um this
problem that you have like the data set
points each point introduces some kind
of Decay around it and your queries
should be able to spot for any
particular query Point what is the sum
of
the the data set points contributing to
that
point okay the connection between this
problem and the our L row problem this
relaxation is going to be that we're
going to be able to
set this parameter the smoothness
parameter in the kernel to be exactly
row over row minus one and we're going
to reduce the problem of
optimizing this this convex program
defined with L this l r Norm
minimization to that of solving the
kernel density estimation and then just
use these
[Applause]
data now um I want to just say okay
because this is a sketching Workshop
this is not super surprising that
smoothness uh makes it easier to solve a
problem with like sampling or sketching
methods in fact I mean the traditional
like first thing I learned about
sketching was the uh sketching for LP
norms and there there's also the case
that the complexity of how well you can
compress or how well you can sketch
these vectors depends on this parameter
P where the non smoothness of the lp
Norm some when p is infinity it's very
sensitive to whether a particular entry
is large or small that's going to be the
value that you're optimizing then
sketching these quanties becomes harder
so it's another way in which smoothness
in the objective makes it very easy for
sampling and sketching based
[Applause]
methods okay so now I'll tell you kind
of what was the the main technical
component I guess of how do we use these
kernel density estimation um sub
routines to solve this modified optimal
transport
problem and here I'm going to just post
back the linear program for the earth
mover distance and I do want to say that
if you look at the literature of like
the spanner approach or these algorithms
for EMD the linear program doesn't play
a very like prominent role because the
size of this linear program is quite
dratic we can't even write it
down um but somehow it's so even
representing the solution gamma is
complicated uh but when we modify the
problem to our l r problem it's going to
turn out to be very useful to look at
what this linear program looks
like okay now the reason why I can't
represent this linear program because
it's too big I can't even hold a
solution gamma uh but the linear program
has two and many constraints
right one constraint for each row and
one constraint for each column so if
instead you looked at the Dual of the S
program then each constraint will now
correspond to a variable and each
variable to a constraint so the number
of variables in the
Dual will be 2 * n okay so already now
I'm I've made progress because I can at
least hold a solution okay so in a way
if you think of instead of minimizing
this quantity optim iing this over some
variables Alpha and beta which
correspond to the constraints on the
rows and the constraints on the columns
at least now it can hold on to an alpha
and beta and try to make progress on
that the challenge of course is that now
I have n squ many constraints so it's
hard for me to determine whether a
particular alpha or beta is in this
feasible set of solutions for the
duel now when you write what happens to
our modified problem
the so I've just changed now the
objective to minimize this L row to the
row
quantity it still has the subjective
function has these two and many
constraints so the Dual will have also
two and many variables however the
constraints are no longer these N
squared many constraints but rather what
you get is you get one
aggregated um quantity which measures
how much you don't satisfy the
constraint so if instead you wanted to
minimize this quantity write the Dual of
this it'll look like something that was
very similar to before however instead
of having these n squ many constraints
you say for each constraint you're going
to have some measure of how much you're
violating the constraint so let me just
go before the constraints were saying
that for each each pair of points points
Alpha I and beta J they can't be further
away than the
distance now I'm going to penal I'm
going to allow you to set Alpha and J
arbitrarily but if you do set them to be
bigger than distance I'm going to
penalize you in the objective
function so here's the term when Alpha I
minus beta J is bigger than the distance
then this expression now becomes bigger
than one and this gets raised to the
power s so as s gets larger and larger
each time you are bigger than one you
get penalized even more for it so if you
were twice as big as a distance you're
going to pay a factor of two to the
S is the yeah okay good oh
sorry yes s is gonna be set exactly to
the Dual Norm of yeah exactly
yeah um
good so yeah so then the thing to notice
is that
this looks very much like a smooth
kernel type of problem in some sense we
have a set of points X and we're
interested in how much does
y these if you think of if you squint
your eyes and you forget about these two
terms Alpha minus beta then this is just
aggregating for each point
Y um what is like the sum of one over
distance to the power
[Applause]
x okay good so really the picture looks
like the following let me compare the
two um I have here the Dual for the EMD
these are the variables Alpha and beta
and each distance gives me a constraint
of alpha minus
beta and I would say find that
point um and here the only difference is
that these n squar many constraints are
getting aggregated together they factor
into the
objective so the picture now is that at
any particular Point Alpha and beta
which you can hold on to every wall of
this polytope is essentially
contributing it's hurting your
objective so okay in this case maybe the
optimum is here if you happen to step
out then this sum here would be very big
this becomes negative and it's hurting
your optimization you're going to move
away from
this okay and the punch line is that
using um kernel density estimation we
can just run first order method so we
can run gradient descent by just
Computing what is the gradient at every
particular point and then taking a step
in this in opposite
direction okay and here is just that
fact that if you if you compute the
gradient in Alpha I and beta J then this
exactly looks like well some constant
that depends on the one/ n and something
that looks like a smooth kernel up to
these Alpha and beta entries which you
hold on
to okay so in the paper we show that
well if you can handle Alpha I minus
beta J this positive term which we give
a data structure to solve this problem
then the rest is a smooth kernel and you
can kind of estimate the gradient in
poly log time so in N poly log n space
in time we can approximate the gradient
we can just run gradi in the
S
okay are there any questions yeah so I
mean like if I think
of if I think of say s as four or 10
right grading descent doesn't really do
great right because the moment the
moment you are below in the less than
one regime your gradients vanish
basically and like you don't get
convergence to like anywhere one you
don't even get poly one or Epsilon
conversion so do you do you have a
translation from estimating gradient to
so maybe this is the reason why our
algorithm it also performs poorly if row
is substantially bigger than one so it's
important for us that row is close to
one um but not so it's bigger than one
but not too far from one so yeah in our
analysis this is where we're using the
fact that at some point if row is set to
some fixed value bigger than one then
yes s the corresponding dual Norm will
be something that is bigger than two and
if it's some fixed constant then we have
to pay some overhead in N but yeah that
mean it did okay I mean yeah maybe we
can take it offline but basically like
once you are at like if row is 1.1 s
looks like 10 or 11 and then uh and then
the gradient vanishes so rapidly that
once you get into the flat gradient
regime you will never basically go to
zero because you need like really large
step sizes even in a one-dimensional
problem uh so you have to do something
to compensate for the fact that
gradients vanish as a power of as a very
high power of how far from the distance
so unless row is exactly two it's not
clear to me why why should like why
vanilla gradient descend with a constant
St size would converge so I'm wondering
if you have a modification no no we
don't have any modification though we
can
see um we'll have to yeah let's talk
about
it to conver or just give a good
solution yeah I mean we just need to
stop what when we're we can prove that
whatever solution we have it's a plus or
minus Epsilon R *
[Applause]
n okay um yeah so let me wrap up I think
this was uh it's pretty much it I can
just say the open problems um first open
problem is just can we be the spanner
approach I started out this talk with uh
with an open problem which I still don't
know how to solve but this is kind of an
orthogonal Direction where we can
algorithmically do something new and
something that goes beyond the spanner
approach using these kernel density
estimation okay again you what other
geometric problems can we approximate
the cost for accurately I think there's
there's a paper of uh shumai and Zar
that they show how to solve the
approximate the cost of the ukian
minimum spanning tree so there are other
kinds of geometric problems for which
you can get good approximations to the
cost
using other kinds of
techniques um and finally our dependence
on Epsilon is is quite bad and one thing
that uh Chris and byy really care about
is that if you're actually running these
methods in practice you need to um have
something that is not meaningless for
epsilon1
something but still the main open
problem I'll leave up uh this is to give
an algorithm for approximating the cost
of EMD in time which is near linear or
to show that doing so would break some
complexity theoretical
[Applause]
assumption just one comment uh for the
syon
algorithm uh you mentioned that gives an
additive Epsilon R but actually it does
that for a modification of the objective
which sort of entropy
normalized yeah yeah so the the
synchron algorithm for the synchron
distance gets add so so so that body of
work modifies the objective in some way
yeah and it turns out it's fine it seems
to work well in practice but all the
conversion results are for this modified
objective that's right and so this is a
different modification
[Applause]
yes any questions for
Eric so at the end of the day the Dual
problem you're solving is sort of the
exact dual problem for the row Norm
problem right yeah uh is there a
particular and it's running gradi
incense I feel like there's results out
there where you know how to get a
relative error result for linear program
solving or like convex optimization
solving it right like where do we end up
having to pay an addtive instead of
something like multiplicative yeah
that's a good question I I we tried
using these
techniques um we couldn't quite get them
to work but it's very possible that you
can get a multiplicative error for this
problem okay just like conceptually
feels like this algorithm should be able
to push out or you think there be like
an algorithmic adjustment to make that
happen the the specific algorithm maybe
you may need to change the algorith
actually the algorithms that you're
referring to um I think they
they solve the problem up to some small
Epsilon and then they change the problem
a little bit solve it that to compute
the difference they do this until
sometime where they use a crude
algorithm so I mean they do change the
algorithm okay cool thank
[Applause]
you any other last
question not let's thank Eric
again and uh today